ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่แอดตี้เยี่ยมสวัสดีครับนัก
เรียนโอเค
นักเรียนผมกลับมาเจอกันนะครับเจอกับ
เพียร์ตีกับน้องเรียมในช่องคล่อง frenzel
ไทยโอเค
ไปแล้วค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้คัดวันนี้ที่เรามาเจอ
กันเป็นวันอะไรคะอ้าวันนี้ใช่ไหมครับวัน
นี้ที่เรามาเจอกันวันอังคารครับ
อ้าวันอังคาร
อังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะหาวันอังคารที่ 3 ครับ
วันนี้
วันที่ 3 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนนี้เดือน R5 ๆ
พฤษภาคมใช้หลายมาคอม
ลบอีกขอศ.อะไรคะปีคศ 2000 ยี่ข้อ 2 ครับ
แล้วปีพ.ศ.อะไรคะพ.ศ
5 ได้ครับ
ตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะพี่อติตอนนี้ใช่ไหม
ครับเดี๋ยวนะอ้าตอนนี้เวลาอา 11 โมง22น
11:22 เข็มยาวต้องอยู่ที่
22  5
แมะฉ่ายาวๆครับน้าเข็มยาวชี้เลข
เข็มสั้นสั้นอ้า 11:00 นเลยเสร็จโมงไป
หน่อยนึงอ่าโอเค
7:20 นน
หิวข้าวหรือยังครับหิวข้าวหรือยัง 11 โมง
เดี๋ยวก็หรือยังล่ะตอนเที่ยงกินข้าว
เที่ยงน่ะหิวข้าวแล้วใช่ไหม
ใช่ค่ะพี่พี่หิวข้าวหรือยังเดี๋ยวตีไม่
หิวครับเคลียร์ติ๊กยังไม่หิว
โอเคถ้ายังไม่หิวก็มาฟังเออเล่าหนังจอห์น
แกวันนี้เรียมจะเล่าหนังอีกใช่ไหมครับวัน
นี้เล่าหนังเรื่องอะไรครับวันนี้
[เพลง]
เท่าหนังเรื่องที่
พระเอกรวยอีกแล้วนี่อ๋อพระเอกบ้วน
หยาบเราก็ก็เขา
เขาฮอได้เลยนะเนี่ยตี้อ๋ออ๋อพระเอกคอได้
ด้วยว้าว
เอกก็ได้ด้วยเรื่องนี้อาบ
หัว
หน้าพระเอก
ที่เดาอ่ะพี่กำลังจะถามว่าถามว่าพระเอก
ฮอตได้แล้วพระเอกใส่ชุดใส่ชุดสีอะไรครับ
พระเอกใส่ชุดสีแดง
ใส่ชุดสีแดงและเหาะได้ด้วยใช่ไหมขอได้ใส่
ชุดสีแดงอยู่นะพี่อาร์ตี้คิดไปถึงเอ่อ
ซุปเปอร์แมน Superman ใส่ชุดสีแดงไหมหรือ
ชุดสีมีสีแดงแล้วก็มีสีน้ำเงินมี 2 สีมี
สีน้ำเงินไหมพระเอกของน้องเรียมเนี่ยใส่
ชุดสีแดงและสีน้ำเงินไหม
ไม่ใช่ค่ะอ๋อไม่มี
ไม่มีสีน้ำเงินไม่มีสีน้ำเงินแล้วมีสี
อะไรอีกครับอีกนิดสีอะไรอีก
มีสีเหลืองอ๋ออ๋อมีสีแดงสีเหลืองโอเค
เฮียตี้คิดว่าถ้ามีสีแดงกับซีนเหลืองน่า
จะเป็นน่าจะเป็นเรื่องเอ่อ Iron  Man แมะ
ไอรอนแมนไหมอ่าถูกต้องถูกต้องด้วยเย้
ไอรอนแมนภาษาที่บอกเลยภาษาไทยชื่ออะไร
ไอรอนแมนชื่ออะไรอ่ะ
R
ชื่อว่าอะไรอาสุภาพบุรุษเจาะเกราะเหล็ก
การต่อเหล็ก
แป้งครับแต่ไอรอนแมนใช่ครับเพราะว่าชุด
ที่เขาใส่ชุดที่เขาใส่เป็นเหล็กเป็นเหล็ก
หน้าลาก็เลยเรียกว่าเกราะเหล็ก
ผมขอเลี้ยงกำลังจะบอกพี่เลยว่าเขาลาที่
ผู้ชายคนนี้เขาหอบขึ้นไปแล้วเขาจะทำมื้อ
นี้ขอ
ปล่อยปล่อยพลังในการเพาะไว้ที่มือใช่ครับ
แล้วก็ไว้ที่เท้าด้วยใช่มั้ยมีที่เท้า
ด้วยแล้วก็มีที่มือด้วยหือนิเธอจะปล่อย
พลังตรงนี้ขอ
[เพลง]
ครับ
Iron  Man มาฟัง Iron  Man จากน้องเรียม
กันวันนี้
Iron  Man มีหลายภาค Iron  Man  1  Iron
Man  2  Iron  Man  3 ไอรอนแมนติกวันนี้
น้องเรียนจะเล่า Iron  Man ภาคไหนครับ
ธาตุไหน
วันนี้จะเล่าภาพที่ 1 ค่ะอ๋อโอเคอ่าเรา
ภาคที่ 1 ก่อนหน้า
ใช่ท่าที่ 1 ฮะคนที่เป็นพระเอกนะคะพี่
ที่จำได้ไหมว่าพระเอกเขาชื่ออะไรนะ
จำได้เขาสินั่งชื่อในหนังใช่ไหมครับชื่อ
โทนี่
โทนี่อ่าใช่ครับโทนี่
โทนี่สตาร์คใต้ครับ
เขามีเขามีบริษัทนะคะมีบริษัทที่ทำเกี่ยว
กับเกี่ยวกับอาเขาเรียกว่าอะไรนะ
จรวดหน้าขายจรวดใช่ไหมครับ
ใช่
ขายจรวดแล้วก็พวกปืน
ๆๆ
จรวด
ปืนแล้วก็มีอะไรครับมีรถถังเอ่อเราเรียก
รวมๆกันเรียกรวมๆกันวะเอาอาวุธ
ใช่แบบข่ายอาวุธโทนี่สตาร์คเนี่ยมีบริษัท
ขายอาวุธ
ใช่
แล้วตอนแรกน่ะบริษัทไม่ใช่ของ Tony สากนะ
คะแต่ว่าเป็นของพ่อของเขาอ๋ออ๋อ Tony ซัก
เป็นลูก
ใช่ธุรี Star เค้าจะมีพ่อมีแม่ใช่ไหมคะ
ขาดแต่ว่าบริษัท
บริษัทชื่อบริษัทอ่าจากอ้าใช่ครับมันจะ
เที่ยวอ้า Industrial ขายอาวุธโอเค
อัน into มั้ยโอเคแล้วที่นี้พ่อเขาก็ตาย
ไป
หน้าครับตอนแรกเค้าก็มีมันจะมีเพื่อนอีก
คนนึง
เพื่อนของพ่อข้อที่ชื่ออะไรนะ
หาเอาบาเด่ฮาอ่ะใช้ครับโอเคโอเค 5 เป็น
ผู้เป็นลุง
เป็นลุงใช่มั้ยไม่เข้าใจว่าแบบเป็นเพื่อน
กันเป็นลุงหรือเป็นอา
อาจจะเป็นอาใช่ๆโอวา Day  5
ทำงานอยู่กับคอกตัวรีดขับต่างๆๆ
บริษัทด้วยกันแต่ว่าพ่อพ่อของโทนี่สตาร์
เขาตายไปแล้วซ้ายขับตรงนี้ตาก็เลยบอกมา
แทนพ่อ
อามาดูแลบริษัทกันกับกุมารีหาอ่าช่วยกับ
ใช่ค่ะแล้วที่นี้มีวันนึงที่โทนี่ซักโดน
จับตัวไปอ๋อโดนจับโดนใครจับตัวไปครับ
สนจับตัวไปลืมจำชื่อไม่ได้นะคะแต่ว่า
เรียมจำได้ว่า
ที่เขา Don't ขอตัวไปเนี่ยอยู่ที่ออฟ
กานิสถาน
มีคนไม่ดีคนไม่ดีมาจับตัวโทนี่สตาร์คไปขอ
กลับไปที่ of กานิสถานให้เขา
ตอนที่เขาโดนจับตัวไปเนี่ยเขาโดนระเบิด
เลยนะคะพี่อาทิตย์โดนระเบิดโดนระบุระเบิด
ตู้
ละเขาก็เลยเหรอไม่สบายนอนไม่สบาย
แล้วก็โดนจับตัวไปในถ้ำ
5 จับตัวนะอ่าจับตัวไปที่ภูเขาจะไปขัง
ไว้ใช่ไหมครับไม่ให้ออกไปไหนอ่ะไม่ให้รู้
ว่าเขาอยู่ที่ไหนอ่ะ
อาจจะได้โทนี่จะได้หนีกลับบ้านไม่ได้ใช่
ไหมเอาไปขังไว้จับไว้ในภูเขาไม่ให้ออกก็
ขับใช่แล้วก็เอาไปโทนี่ไปไว้ในถ้ำในภูเขา
อ่าแล้วในนี้เค้าจะมีหมออีกคนนึงนะคะอ๋อ
อ๋อมีหมอคนที่มาเอ่อดูแลโทนี่ใช่ไหมครับ
เพราะว่าตอนนี้โทนี่ตอนที่โทนี่โดนจับ
โทนี่โดนระเบิดโดนระเบิดมาแล้วก็โทนี่ก็
เจ็บได้รับบาดเจ็บหน้าบาดเจ็บก็เลยต้อง
ให้หมอมาช่วยดูแลโทนี่แม่ชายก็เลยอยู่ใน
ถ้ำกัน 2 คนปีหมอแล้วก็โทนี่ครับอยู่ใน
ถ้ำคน
หมอก็ช่วยโทนี่ช่วยให้เขาเอาอะไรนะแม่
เหล็กติดไว้ตรงนี้ค่ะอ๋ออ๋อครับใช่เพราะ
ว่าตอนที่ตอนที่โทนี่โดนระเบิดเนี่ยตอน
ที่โทนเราโดนระเบิดนะหน้าอาระเบิดมันจะมี
ความอ่ามันจะเข้าวิ่งเข้าไปที่หัวใจหน้า
นี้หัวใจของโทนีแล้วระเบิดเนี่ยที่โดน
เนี่ยมันจะพยายามวิ่งเข้าไปที่หัวใจนะหมอ
ก็เลยสร้างเกราะสร้างเกราะป้องกัน
ป้องกันไม่ให้ไม่ให้ระเบิดวิ่งเข้าไปที่
หัวใจก็เลยใส่เกาะไว้ตรงตรงกลางอกโพนี่
ตรงนี้คือหน้าอกนายครับ
อันนี้คือตรงกลางหน้าอกติดไว้เพื่อไม่ให้
แบบสะเก็ดเล็กๆยิ่งเข้าหาหัวใจๆเขาเนี่ย
ไม่ได้นั่นแหละแล้วคนที่จับตัวโทนี่มาเขา
ก็บอกให้โทนี่คำ
ทำเหมือนแบบจรวด
ก็ขอบวชให้เขาครับหน้าเขาอยากจะให้โทนี่
เนี่ยช่วยหล่อสร้างอาวุธอาวุธอันใหม่ให้
เขาก็เขาอยากได้อยากได้อาวุธเขารู้ว่าเขา
รู้ว่าโทนี่สตาร์กเนี่ยเก่งสามารถสร้าง
ระเบิดได้ก็เลยจับโพนี่ซักไปสร้างระเบิด
ใครเขา
ใช่แล้วโทนี่ทำยังไงครับมีสิ่งนี้ให้ขับ
เขาจะมีแบบพวกระเบิดมีระเบิด
มีปืนเหงาในหลายๆอย่างเยอะมากๆครับแล้ว
เขาให้โทรนี่มาแกะ
แกะน้อ
ทำ
เรียกเหมือนเลี่ยมเงี้ยมันก็จะแกะลำโพง
อ้าวแก่เอาเอาแค่
We  Are  One บางส่วนเอาบางส่วนไปไป
ประกอบเป็นเอ่อ
อาวุธอันใหม่หนาวุฒิอันใหม่โดยใช้ส่วน
ประกอบจากอาวุธหลายๆอันมารวมกันเป็น
ระเบิดอันใหม่อ่ะ
ครับก็เลยเอามาประกอบประกอบประกอบประกอบ
กันครับให้เป็น
ตัวนี้คุณจรวดใช่มั้ยมันจะไม่
อาจจะไปจับมันระเบิดได้ใช่ครับ
แล้ว
Tony ที่อยู่ในถ้ำเขาก็โอเค
เอาหลายๆอย่างมารวมกันแต่ว่าเขาไม่คิดที่
จะทำระเบิดนะอ๋ออ๋ออ้าวไม่ได้ทำระเบิด
แล้วโทนี่ทำอะไรครับ
เขาใช้ดินสอนะคะอะไรสักอย่างนี่แหละวาด
รูป
วาดรูป
มีชุดเกาะ
ชุดเกาะขึ้นมาอ๋อแล้วเขาก็เอาทุกๆอย่างมา
ทำเป็นชุด
ชุดเหล็กครับ
คำชุดเหล็กเสร็จแล้วเขาก็หนีออกมาจากถ้ำ
น้อ
หน้าอ่า
นี่ย์ออกมาได้ไหมหนีเอามาจากถ้ำได้ไหม
ครับ
หนีออกมาจากถ้ำได้ค่ะพี่อ่ะดีครับผมแม่
ใช่เข้ามาข้างนอกออกมาจากถ้ำเรียบร้อย
แล้วเขาก็มาบอกทุกคนว่าเขาจะไม่ทำไม่ทำ
ระเบิดขอ
หือทำไม่ทำใช่เราก็
จะไม่ทำจรวดแบบนี้ขอขอว่าจะเลิกทำอาวุธ
ใช่ไหมครับไม่ทำอาวุธขายและอ๋อครับไม่ทำ
เอาอุดเขาก็เลยว่าจะไป
ทำ
เครื่องปฏิกรณ์ Art
เครื่องปฏิกรณ์ R ที่มันจะมีพลังงาน
พลังงานเยอะๆ
นั่นแหละครับแล้ว
ตอนนี้พี่เรียกอะไรแต่พวกเราพี่โทนี่
ไส้ก็เป็นพี่ครับตอนนี้นี่ครับ
เทียบพี่จำโอมาร์โอมาร์ they  are ได้ไหม
จำได้ครับจำ mobile หาได้
ใช่เขาก็เลยบอกว่าโคนี่ไม่สบายไม่สบาย
ๆก็กลับไปอยู่ที่บ้านก่อนดีกว่าเขาว่าเขา
น่ะก็อยากผลิตละก็อยากทำอาวุธอีกอยากขาย
อาวุธเพราะขายอาวุธได้เงินได้เงินเยอะนะ
แต่โทนี่ไม่อยากทำไม่อยากทำ
ใช่ค่ะแล้วโทนี่ก็เลยกลับไปอยู่ที่บ้าน
บ้านหลังใหญ่มากๆนะ
แล้วก็เขาก็ไปทำ
นุ่นยนต์
ทำชุดเกราะถ้าทำชุดใหม่ใช่ไหมทำชุดใหม่
ทั้งชุดใหม่
ก็เลยได้เป็นชุด Ironman
จะแวะส่วนมั้ยเนี่ย
เน็ตไอรอนแมนโอเค
เร็วไม่กล้าว่าใช่มั้ยไม่เป็นไรในก็วาด
อย่าลืมว่าอย่างนี้ดีกว่ามันจะได้เหมือน
คุณยนต์ไงอ่ะโอเคอันนี้เป็นตัวแรกเอาอ่ะ
เนื้อหาเป็นตัวที่ 1 นั่นไอรอนแมนตัวแรก
แทงอ้าวขับ
นี่แหละเขาก็ทำเสร็จแล้วก็ที่อะไรนะ
omarion อ่ะเขาก็เลย
เขาก็เลยมาหามาหาโทนีตาแล้วก็จะเอาชุดไป
กับ
เขาก็ตอนนั้นน่ะเขาเอาชุดเก่าชุดเก่าตอน
ที่หนีออกมาจากถ้ำกับ
ฟันตอนที่หนีออกมาจากท่านนะคะจะมีอยู่ชุด
นึงเออ
มารีอาก็เอาแบบเครื่องที่ติดอยู่นะอกของ
โทนี่สตาร์คออกครับแล้วก็ไปใส่ของตัวเอง
แล้วก็โทนี่ 3 ในเขาก็จะมีอันนี้อีกอัน
นึงเขาทำใหม่แล้วใช่ไหมก็มาทำที่ป้องกัน
สะเก็ดระเบิดวิ่งเข้าหัวใจอันใหม่ที่บ้าน
ทำใหม่แล้วช่างน่าใช่ครับอันเก่าก็เลยไป
แล้ว
ใช่แต่ว่าตัวใหม่เนี่ยโดน omarion เอาไปๆ
34 หาเขาก็เลยแบบโอ้ยเจ็บไปเอาอันเก่ามา
นอนเก่ากลับมาใส่เหมือนเดิมเหรอ
ใช่แล้วก็มาสู้ๆกันภาพ
ก็เลยมีเหมือนแบบหุ่นยนต์ 2 ตัว 5 หุน
ยนต์ 2 ตัวสู้กันตัวนึงตัวนึงตัวนึงเป็น
Iron  Man เป็นโทนี่สตาร์คใช่มั้ยอาอีก
ตัวหนึ่งเป็นโอบายหาใช่ไหม
ถ้าสู้กัน 2 ตัว
Iron  Man กันสุดท้าย Tony ซักสู้ได้ไหม
สู้สู้เหมือนกันนะชนะโอบายหาไหม
ตอนแรกตอนแรกคิดว่าเรียนคิดว่าไม่ชนะอ๋อ
ตอนแรกไม่ชนะใช่ไหมครับแล้วโทนี่โทนี่ทำ
ยังไงถึงชนะโอ By  Day หาได้ครับคนนี่โท
นี่ก็บอกบอก Paper  Paper  Pot ขับที่
เป็นเหมือนเลขาของเขานะคะครับเป็นเลขผู้
หญิง
ใช่ก็เลยบอกบอกว่าเปิดเครื่องปฏิกรณ์ Art
อ๋อ
เพราะว่า
โทรมาดีอายุตรงนี้ขอขอเปิดเครื่องมันก็มี
พลังงานเยอะๆครับแล้วพลังงานก็ช็อตขอเข้า
ไป
ทำให้โอบายาไม่ใช่มะหัวหน้าสวัสดีหาก็
ร่วงลงไปในเครื่องแล้วก็ระเบิดดูไอ้โอนิ
สาก็เลยฉันนะโอเคว้าวหนู
ในภาคที่ 1 นะคะตอนที่โทนี่สตาร์คออกไป
พูด
พูดต่อหน้าหลายๆคนครับก็จะมีคนคิดอยู่ว่า
โทนี่สตาร์กกับพูดว่าอะไร
ตอนที่โทนี่กลับมาแล้วค่ะแล้วเขาก็ต้องไป
ยืน
ให้สัมภาษณ์ตรงนี้เป็นโพเดียมออกน้ำมันก็
จะมีใหม่
ขับ
แล้วเขาก็ต้องไปยืนแล้วก็พูดพูดพูดๆอาบๆ
พี่คนข้างล่างที่แบบเป็นนักข่าว
ข่าวข่าวหลายๆนะคะ
เขาก็จะถามว่า
อ่ะหรอนี่มากไอรอนแมนคือใครอ๋ออ๋อเพราะ
ว่าเพราะว่าตอนที่โทนี่เป็น Iron  Man
ใส่ชุดเกราะไม่เห็นหน้าใช่ไหมไม่มีใคร
เห็นหน้าของโทนี่นักข่าวก็เลยอยากรู้อยาก
รู้ใครใครคือไอรอนแมนก็เลยถามโทนี่ใช่ไหม
ครับ
ใช่ค่ะถามโทนี่โทนี่ก็เลยบอกว่าผมคือ
ไอรอนแมน
ผมคือไอรอนแมนนั่นเองยัง
ไม่เอาภาพที่ 1 ก็
จบจอบน้าจบตรงที่อาจโทนี่บอกว่าผมคือ
ไอรอนแมนใช่ไหมอ่า
ใช่แล้วว้าว
หน้าเป็นยังไงบ้างครับ Iron  Man เรียก
เป็นไอรอนแมนมั้ย
เปียตีคิดว่าเป็น Iron  Man นะก็ไม่สนุก
ไม่สนุก
ๆกับต้องทำงานหลายอย่างใจๆเหรอนึก
โอเคโอเคแต่ว่าคนนี้เวลาหมดแล้วค่ะพี่
อาร์ตี้มาหมดแล้วเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าเรามาต่อ
กันนะครับว่าเพี้ยนพี่กับน้องเรียมจะมี
หนังสนุกๆอะไรมันเล่าให้นักเรียนฟังกันนะ
ครับโอเคเดี๋ยวๆค่ะสำหรับวันนี้ต้องลาไป
ก่อนแล้วใจกับอาลาไปก่อนครับสวัสดีครับ
นักเรียน
ครับอ่าสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีครับ
สวัสดีค่ะพี่บ๊ายบาย